now these questions I'm gonna walk
through these examples from the second
exercise of bookmark for second external
platform so if you want you can turn
there okay how do these questions work
okay all we're doing is we're theni back
to the very first time we looked at any
three unit shrink topic right
but first what Street expansions if you
remember we used it because we needed it
for the first principles proof of the
derivative of sign anyway so we like
these guys right um sign a plus B what's
that equal to
Richard Tong you can told me so you do
know trig expansions after all okay so
so this is C extensions right so this is
not inverse trig expansions this is just
regular old transactions but have a look
at what's different okay
instead of a and B some arbitrary angles
that a and B that we are looking at are
in terms of inverse trig okay so how are
we going to do this right if we write
out the regular expansion first okay
which which looks like this okay but we
put sine inverse whatever in place off
of a and B now show us where we should
go for the next step okay so let's just
reverse the expansion sign now this is a
right cause and this is B sine a cos B
plus cos a back to the first angle okay
now let's have a look at this we can
work with some of this right
actually we come back with all about the
song it's easier than others have a look
at this guy for instance sine of sine
inverse okay and you remember we were
doing some work with trying to work out
with the graph all this look like okay
well how good your memory right it's got
a restriction on it it's got a
restriction the restriction comes
through the restriction of the inside
function so this part is 4 minus 1 to 1
right so the whole one is from minus 1
to 1 and it'll look like that in that
domain okay now 4/5 is that within the
domain that we're interested in it is
right so too much my 1 so therefore I
could just say it's equal to that value
because it's within the domain where
this statement is true so fun I'll leave
this guy for a second we'll come back to
him this one as well this is in the same
boat as before is it in the domain
answer yes it's between minus 1 at once
though open 13 right so this is just
gonna be I'm gonna write it and keep
it's gonna compress in a second sinus is
it swollen 13 is just one minute okay
now you've got these guys which are
mixed up yeah and yeah how do we go
about these right now what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to show you graphically how
I think through it the eventually when
you just once you start to get
comfortable with these questions you
will not have to do it graduate it's
really
easy to do in your head okay let's have
a look at this guy sine inverse of 12 on
30 now the whole premise of this
expansion is that I'm thinking of these
as angles calling this any way then
calling this a will be right so angle
NAB they exist in triangles right
because in this domain minus ones one
these angles should be a cute right so I
can draw a right angle triangle with Amy
and with B in it right so this is angle
B here let's do that one first
let's try angle be there okay
now sine inverse of 12 on 13 right this
is my angle B what ratio does that give
me in this travel sign is opposite on
hypotenuse opposite so this is B so it's
just terribly not to scale but you get
the idea okay
opposite on hypotenuse is 12 or 13 okay
now because that's nice easy numbers
right you can see that the third side is
going to equal to okay now what I want
is cos B right angle and closes adjacent
of my point so it's 530 that's cause of
side of this to over 30 last now I can
run how does the process here okay
instead of a five twelve thirteen
triangle which I got from this ratio you
can probably predict here without
drawing it what kind of triangle does
this come from what are the three sytem
equal to so take your factoring okay now
in that triangle this is this angle a
right where is a
it's a its its opposite hypotenuse might
search for is opposite okay so I want
colors of that angle up there which is
adjacent long hypotenuse so there's all
my evaluation all right that was the
hard part
okay just working out where it's going
now like I said do you need to draw
these triangles well when you get these
kinds of questions you don't have 90% of
them at least okay I'm just gonna give
you nice Pythagorean numbers okay so you
won't need to you can get to five top 30
that's an eighth 15 17 or whatever okay
you don't really need to put that down
while you're still trying to get the
hang of it I think obviously dry it will
help you right now I'm gonna combine
these two fractions together since I'm
going to combine and I want the colored
denominator in the end even though I
could cancel these fires I might as well
just keep them right because that'll
mean there's 65 here and 65 here so I'm
looking to cancel those out I'm just
gonna get everything over 65 the first
ones 20 the second ones 36 so here's
your answer
okay now just to mention you know you
actually can just like with a single one
of these questions here like if I want
to work out what that is I could
actually just get my calculator out and
I could put that in exactly the same way
if you're patient you can't there now
you can punch that whole expression in
and your time good isn't big enough that
they can handle this fraction so you
just get that answer out okay well Sam I
said yesterday which is that a question
like this will usually be worth two
marks okay so two mics in client you
can't just put down a ball answer that
will just get you one you need to
demonstrate something of understanding
how did you get from there to there
well what schools are actually used and
the main one is the expansion right so I
would say you need to put either this
line or this line in if you want to go
straight there okay at least one of
these has to be intermediate okay now
naturally
would prefer to probably put down this
line because it's short up Ryan I think
this is a better option even though it
takes so much longer to write okay
number one it shows a better
understanding of like these are
distractions who knows where they came
from
really okay but secondly suppose you
what these fractions are all right in
section one and then you you're finished
X before you come back and then you're
like mmm is this right or wrong you look
at these fractions I don't know how are
you going to tell whether those are
right or wrong if you don't know where
they came from so this line on the other
hand you can actually do some
backtracking you can you can debug you
can work out for an error from this line
much better from this line